your lovely wife Susan a gorgeous
talented woman how's it going how do you
guys would you like to do when you get
home and there's no personal question
but okay well you know what well yeah
actually what we did do last weekend and
we look at we love to look at open
houses guys like I don't buy it I don't
buy it but yeah okay but I noticed that
realtor's are a little duplicitous when
it comes to trying to sell you a house
or get you excited about it here's what
they do you know after they're almost
finished showing the house they go you
know we're not supposed to say this but
two blocks down Julia Roberts lips I'm
not supposed to say anything about that
you know as if you'd be happy being that
say that but they do that stuff
sometimes I take it too far you know
we're not supposed to say this but Joe
Pesci lives in the room upstairs
he very rarely comes up it shouldn't be
a problem shouldn't be a problem that's
nicer you go when you look at these
houses that's nice that you get out
there and you enjoy life you know well I
didn't say it enjoyed it yeah yeah no
but it is fun you have a know I really
don't often know I because you're happy
with your house I'm happy where I live
and we're deal if I were ever live
exactly yeah I'm happy I'm pretty much
an open book I live on Catalina Island
so good to know good to know yeah I now
live in a geodesic dome on Catalina
Island I found this beautiful beach on
Catalina Island I don't know if you've
ever seen it it's like right on the
water
beautiful where is our waiter
[Laughter]
[Applause]